Not every remake has to be bad.
Some are marked improvements over the original,
others are able to reimagine things just enough
to stay fresh and interesting.
Let's take a look at a genre that often does
well with modern updates: horror.
This is a bit of an odd one.
Fantasy Island was a TV series that debuted
in the late 1970s and ran for seven seasons.
It starred Ricardo Montalban as Mr. Roarke,
the caretaker of the titular island where
guests paid a premium fee to live out their
deepest fantasies.
The show typically dealt in intrigue, wonder,
and the occasional drama, although some of
the guests' fantasies took a turn into Twilight
Zone-esque territory.
Just a little twist, and you've got yourself
a horror movie.
Blumhouse is bringing Fantasy Island to the
21st century and the big screen, leaning hard
into the horrific potential of the concept.
This time, the island is shown twisting people's
wishes beyond their control and creating dangerous,
horrifying scenarios.
The movie stars Michael Pena in Montalban's
role, and also features Lucy Hale, Michael
Rooker, and Parisa Fitz-Henley.
It's directed by Jeff Wadlow, who directed
Truth or Dare and has produced some successful
horror television.
Fantasy Island is an interesting choice for
a horror reboot, as the show always had a
sinister undercurrent but generally shied
away from outright scares.
Hopefully making the horrors of granting secret
wishes more overt won't dilute the appeal.
For being such a product of the '90s, the
original version of The Craft still holds
up pretty well.
The story of a group of high school girls
exacting revenge through magical powers is
a good one, and the central cast of Robin
Tunney, Neve Campbell, Rachel True, and Fairuza
Balk go through awesome transformations as
the film builds to its conclusion.
"Aw, relax, it's only magic."
The reboot of The Craft is coming along nicely.
Blumhouse has announced that the witches in
their new version will be played by Cailee
Spaeny, Gideon Adlon, Lovie Simone, and Zoey
Luna.
The remake is written and directed by Zoe
Lister-Jones.
One thing that bodes very well for The Craft
reboot is how many people who were involved
with the original film are also involved with
the update.
Douglas Wick, who produced the original, is
back as a producer on the reboot, and the
original film's director, Andrew Fleming,
is also involved in a producer role.
There have been a lot of very unsubstantial
rumors floating around out there about a return
to Elm Street, especially with the runaway
success of 2018's Halloween reboot-slash-sequel.
Now, according to Bloody Disgusting, we can
really expect a new Nightmare on Elm Street
film to start production in the near future,
but that's about all we know so far.
"Actually, it's been giving me Freddy nightmares."
In 2010, there was an attempt to reboot A
Nightmare on Elm Street with Jackie Earle
Haley playing the lead villain.
Unfortunately, the reboot was panned by critics
and audiences alike, and the franchise faded
into the background.
In September of 2019, Wes Craven's estate
regained the rights to the character and franchise.
Bloody Disgusting reports that the horror
master's estate is actively seeking pitches
for the return of Freddy Krueger.
The site reports that they are accepting pitches
for both a feature film and a possible HBO
series.
Obviously, this information is all tied to
the very beginning of the process.
That said, it seems it won't be too long before
A Nightmare on Elm Street comes back to haunt
us.
Interestingly enough, what's thought of as
the classic version of The Fly is, itself,
a remake.
Most people think of the 1986 film led by
Jeff Goldblum as the definitive version, but
the original film actually came out in 1958
and starred horror legend Vincent Price.
Despite radically different tones and levels
of disturbing imagery, the two start from
the same basic concept, and both the 1958
film and the 1986 one spawned sequels.
Considering it's been over 30 years since
Goldblum portrayed Dr. Seth Brundle, of course
it's about time for a reboot.
Some were worried that Disney's purchase of
Fox would put the kibosh on more adult fare
like The Fly, but apparently that isn't the
case.
According to Movie Hole, The Fly is in no
danger of falling by the wayside.
It will be interesting to see if they keep
with the teleporter as the culprit, or if
they switch things up in the third go around.
Despite the fact that it was essentially riding
on the coattails of Scream, I Know What You
Did Last Summer actually became a pretty hot
property in the late 1990s.
The original film was a veritable who's who
of heartthrob actors: Jennifer Love Hewitt,
Sarah Michelle Gellar, Ryan Phillippe, and
Freddy Prinze Jr. all did battle with "The
Fisherman" in the campy slasher flick.
Fans can rejoice: I Know What You Did Last
Summer is returning, this time as an Amazon
Prime series.
"What are you waiting for, huh?!"
James Wan is attached to the series as a producer,
and Bloody Disgusting reports that the series'
pilot is written by Shay Hatten.
Hatten also wrote the screenplay for John
Wick 3: Parabellum.
No director that we know of is attached for
the pilot episode at this point.
I Know What You Did Last Summer told the story
of a group of teens who run over someone with
their car and dump the body in the ocean.
The next year, the group starts receiving
threats from someone who knows their secret,
and they begin to get killed by a person in
a raincoat carrying a hook.
Night of the Comet is an oft-forgotten classic,
and a reboot of the low-budget science fiction
flick could do wonders for the story.
Roxanne Benjamin, who started out as a producer
on horror films like V/H/S and The Devil's
Candy before moving into writing and directing,
is attached to the project.
Night of the Comet finds the earth passing
through the tail of a comet, wiping out almost
all of humanity.
Our heroes are two sisters who try to search
for answers while fighting off zombies.
It's a campy girl power film that has become
a bit of a cult favorite in the years since
its release in 1984.
The original film starred Catherine Mary Stewart
and Kelli Maroney.
Benjamin told Birth.Movies.Death that she
has submitted her screenplay for the reboot,
and that she hopes the studio will approach
her to direct the movie if they decide to
go ahead with it.
Don't expect it anytime soon, however, as
it's, quote, "still very early days."
Wrong Turn is a surprisingly recent film to
be receiving the remake treatment, but well,
that's how the business works these days.
The original film came out in 2003 and spawned
several sequels, with the most recent being
2014's Wrong Turn 6: Last Resort.
Strangely, the reboot is being penned by Alan
McElroy, who created the franchise to begin
with.
That's good news for fans of the series; if
anyone can get a reboot right, hopefully it's
the man who created the series.
The Domestics' Mike P. Nelson is attached
to direct, with a cast led by Emma Dumont,
Dylan McTee, and Charlotte Vega.
The original Wrong Turn followed a group of
friends who get lost in rural West Virginia,
and are terrorized by a cannibalistic family
as they struggle to escape.
According to Coming Soon:
"The Wrong Turn reboot will feature a cross-country
hiking expedition that puts a group of friends
in the land of an inclusive society called
The Foundation, described as people who have
lived in the mountains since before the Civil
War."
Another reboot with some strange names attached
to it is Saw.
The original film was released in 2004, and
quickly became a horror juggernaut.
Despite a paltry budget of just over one million
dollars, Saw made over $100 million worldwide
and spawned a massive franchise.
Director James Wan has gone on to become a
huge star in the industry, and the latest
sequel came out as recently as 2017.
And now, Chris Rock; yes, that Chris Rock;
is rebooting the franchise for Lionsgate.
Rock will feature in the film and serve as
the executive producer.
Darren Lynn Bousman, who directed the second,
third, and fourth Saw films, is at the helm
again.
Max Minghella, Marisol Nichols, and Samuel
L. Jackson star.
The original Saw series got more and more
insane as the sequels piled up, but it originally
focused on a serial killer who placed people
in elaborate puzzles to see "how much they
wanted to live."
"I want to play a game."
With Rock and Bousman's reboot, hopefully
some of the magic will return to the franchise.
Quick quiz: how many Hellraiser movies have
there been?
Answer: Ten!
There are ten.
And the most recent one, Hellraiser: Judgment,
came out in 2018.
That said, Spyglass Entertainment is trying
to revitalize the franchise a bit with a reboot.
Yes, the Lament Configuration is headed back
to the big screen, bringing Pinhead and the
rest of the Cenobites with it.
The Dark Knight's David S. Goyer is attached
to the reboot as both a writer and producer.
Clive Barker, who wrote the original story
the series is based on and directed the first
film in 1987, is also attached.
Hellraiser never quite reached the level of
massive horror franchises like A Nightmare
on Elm Street or Halloween, but its dark and
twisted narrative and memorable villain did
help the series carve out its own fandom.
The story revolves around a puzzle box that,
when solved, unleashes a gang of demons into
our world.
The leader of these demons is Pinhead, one
of the most iconic horror villains of the
1980s.
Goyer is excited to be given a chance with
the franchise.
He told Deadline:
"Having the chance to reimagine Pinhead and
the Cenobites for a new audience is a nightmare-come-true."
What's that?
A successful movie from another country?
In true American fashion, Train to Busan is
getting a western remake; the buzzworthy zombie
film out of Korea is in development from James
Wan and Gary Dauberman.
If you like zombie films, you can't do much
better than Train to Busan.
The 2016 film follows a group of people stuck
on a moving train as a zombie virus spreads.
It features some absolutely gruesome scenes
and some very inventive set pieces, and the
naturally claustrophobic setting is prime
for an outbreak.
There aren't a lot of details on the remake
at this point in time, but it should be in
good hands with Wan and Dauberman, two of
the leaders in recent horror success stories.
Speaking with Entertainment Weekly, Dauberman
explained his approach to the source material:
"I'm being very careful how we translate it
over here.
And really my rule is, Don't f-- it up!"
This one is still extremely early in development,
but we do have a few concrete details on the
remake of this obscure gem.
Audrey Rose was released in 1977, a bizarre
little horror mystery starring Marsha Mason
and Anthony Hopkins.
Mason plays Janice, a woman with a daughter
whose life is turned upside down when Hopkins'
Elliot Hoover shows up.
He insists that Janice's daughter is actually
a reincarnation of his own dead child, and
all sorts of creepy events start occurring.
It's a slow burn, but one that could be very
impressive with the right people telling the
modern adaptation.
All we know so far about the remake of Audrey
Rose is that it is being released by Orion
Pictures and the screenplay is being hammered
out by Chloe Okuno.
Okuno seems like just the writer to put together
a creepy, surreal story like Audrey Rose.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.